[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon ça y est
alors jetez plus
[Applaudissements]
quant à lucho copico china et footloose
disparu au contraire
[Musique]
le monde
bonjour à toutes et à tous je suis pour
brut à hong kong un territoire semi
autonome de la chine où se déroulent des
manifestations géantes depuis le début
du mois de juin avec des centaines de
milliers de manifestants dans la rue
donc là il ya une confrontation au coeur
de la ville de hong kong
là les manifestants qui sont toutes en
coup là bas et qui utilise des lasers
pour essayer d'aveuglés la police est
juste derrière moi les gars la police
qui défend le commissariat de quartier
ces partis sont en train de charger les
manifestants qui sont de l'autre côté
plusieurs policiers en civil qui en
réussit à arrêter un groupe de
manifestants qui étaient un petit peu à
l'écart qui sont en train de les
maîtriser il ya pas mal de mecs qui sont
quand le visage ensemble
[Musique]
la situation est très tendue là ils ont
aligné les manifestants qu'ils ont
arrêtés parce contre un mur les mains
ligotées
[Applaudissements]
pour bien comprendre cette révolte que
je viens de filmer à hong kong il faut
que je vous parle d'un projet de loi qui
a mis le feu aux poudres
ce texte aurait facilité l'extradition
de criminels vers la chine continentale
et c'est ça qui a poussé les ont conviés
dans la rue il ya eu des manifs monstres
contre cette loi en juin et face à la
pression de la rue début juillet la
patronne du gouvernement de hong kong a
dû reculer en musée mais des clés pour
l'instant sauf qu'en réalité le projet
de loi a juste été suspendus pas
complètement enterrée et c'est pour ça
que la mobilisation a continué tout
l'été les manifestants ont demandé
l'annulation définitive de la loi sur
l'extradition plus de démocratie a hong
kong la démission de la patronne du
gouvernement ainsi que la libération de
toutes les personnes arrêtées
bref beaucoup de revendications mais au
final ils n'ont pas obtenu grand chose
si ces manifestants ne lâche rien c'est
parce que le temps joue contre eux
depuis 1997
hong kong est un territoire semi
autonome de la chine avec ses propres
lois
mais ce statut particulier il n'est pas
éternel dans 28 ans en 2047 hong kong re
deviendra une province chinoise comme
les autres
[Musique]
pour souder les barricades entre elles
il utilise des bracelets en plastique
qui sont hyper résistant est en fait
après c'est très très dur de séparer les
barricades et ça ralentit énormément les
forces de l'ordre dans cette
manifestation il ya principalement des
jeunes qui sont tous très bien équipés
ils ont des protections comme des
casques des lunettes des masques à gaz
ils ont aussi des gants ignifuges et
pour amasser les gaz lacrymogènes et se
mettent aussi du film plastique sur les
bras et sur les jambes quand ils sont en
short pour se protéger des effets des
gaz lacrymogènes qui peuvent être très
irritant pour la peau
[Applaudissements]
la plupart des manifestations ont lieu
devant des lieux symboliques ou des
lieux de pouvoir comme des commissaires
de police ou des bâtiments
administratifs du gouvernement c'est
comme ça bougeait la police fait les
premiers avertissements
ce drapeau ils indiquent qu'ils vont
faire usage de gaz lacrymogènes ces
partis et forces de l'ordre sont en
train de sortir
ouais les premiers tirs de gaz
lacrymogène de la part des forces de
l'ordre paris
elles ont mis en place pas mal de
stratégies pour éteindre les gaz
lacrymogènes notamment avec des cônes de
signalisation ensuite à l'intérieur il
met de l'eau et du sel soleil
[Musique]
à chaque fin de charge la police arrive
dans des endroits déserts parce que
souvent les manifestants se met à côté
des stations de métro comme ça ils
peuvent partir très rapidement aller à
la prochaine et installé un nouveau
barrage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la prennent le métro on sait pas trop où
on va il ya des gens devant et si du
prochain endroits où ils sont censés
aller manifester
il ya une énorme solidarité reçues en
permanence des gens qui laissent de
l'argent au dessus des machines qui
vendent les tickets de métro pour que
tout le monde puisse acheter un ticket
m
[Musique]
nyse
pressman quand ça venait la stratégie de
se déplacer en permanence en fait c'est
ce qu'ils appellent le be watching est
comme de l'eau idc en fait de ne jamais
rentrer en confrontation directe avec la
police locale éviter au maximum pour ne
pas céder
et se déplaçait en ferme à nancy
[Musique]
là on est dans un quartier très
touristique ont pris car il ya
énormément de passants en fait des
civils qui applaudissent les
manifestants et qui demande à la police
de partir
[Applaudissements]
si on est tirés d'affairé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on paye à une série qui vient de se
faire arrêter parce qu'elle criait des
slogans anti police
du coup il ya une nouvelle manifestation
qui vient de se fermer suite à
l'arrestation de cette passante c'est
que des civils qu'ils se déplacent ils
n'ont pas du tout les équipements de
manifestations habituelles
des faits
du
willis ils sont en train de plier il
demande la libération en fait de la
passante qui vient d'être arrêté
ils viennent de tirer des gaz
lacrymogènes sur la population civile
à
dommage
il ya aussi un truc qui m'a beaucoup
marqué quand je filmais sur place c'est
cette solidarité entre les générations
j'ai filmé des manifs avec des jeunes
mais je suis aussi allé dans des
manifestations de parents avec leur bébé
dans la poussette et il avait un message
pour la police when i'm sorry
[Applaudissements]
je viens d'arriver à l'aéroport de hong
kong où actuellement des milliers de
manifestants font un sit in qui va durer
plusieurs heures jusque tard dans la
nuit et le message est évidemment
symbolique il est d'alerter le reste du
monde sur ce qu'il se passe à hong kong
mais aussi d'interpeller les touristes
qui arrivent pour leur expliquer la
situation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
gardiens
eh les gars
m
est ce vrai
[Applaudissements]
et un talent
m
[Applaudissements]
anthony monde car il n'y a pas que les
manifestants ont kong et qui s'adresse
au reste du monde
le régime de pékin aussi cet été ils ont
diffusé ce clip de propagande avec un
message très clair si les manifestations
continuent il pourrait intervenir
militairement
[Applaudissements]
l'aea
[Musique]
mais à paris mme souid de près du foyer
a redit au rond-point will traumat à ba1
d'espoir
honda a droit elle
m
et les we can't you get
puis pour ses revendications pour plus
de démocratie
les hong kong et les martèle depuis
maintenant des mois et le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est que la communauté
internationale reste très timide dans
son soutien en 2019
y'a pas grand monde pour oser s'opposer
au géant chinois
[Musique]
un gardien